now I'm sure there's a lot of changes
you'd like to make in your life I really
want to start waking up at 5:00 a.m.
every morning I need friends I want to
eat pizza and have sex at the same time
what whatever it is you want to do you
can fucking do it
it's so simple all you have to do is
change your habits I mean think about it
we are whatever it is we mostly do so it
makes sense that the way to becoming who
you want to be is to do that thing that
you want to do all the time every day
even if you start off small there I am
where I turn now all that matters is
consistency I cannot emphasize that
enough consistency so many people take
that for granted or think that making a
big change is impossible and it's not
it's really not it just takes time
because usually the kind of changes we
want to make our lifestyle changes so
why not start living the life you want
now even if you have to start off with
small steps just make that a routine
ingrained that habit and before you know
it you'll see results next time let's
try pepperoni so I hope whatever it is
you want to do or whoever you wanted to
come you start taking those small steps
now see you next week stay awesome
Gotham oh let me just let me just walk
down the stairs huh now for real is what
those are real this is step butter this
is step butter I'm standing on a
stepladder doing this for you for this
background okay so start making your
fucking lifestyle changes now please